we got this couple man woman right what
does society like what do we need for
society to work we need a house
um we might need the internet right I
mean we don't we don't need it but we we
all you know we need a car
hypothetically we live in like I know I
can't draw I can't draw so just you know
bear with me
um we need electricity we need plumbing
and what percent of women do these jobs
I can't really think of one job where
women Dominate and that we need what up
guys welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel today I am going to be
giving a special whiteboard presentation
called ladies you are not as special as
you think well actually a better a
better name for this would be ladies
you're not as important as you think yes
now I get a lot of hate for for I got a
lot of hate this week for a tweet that I
said that said men make Society run and
women don't our jobs we could all the
women women could stop working tomorrow
so what do I mean by that what if we
have a society right so we got a guy
here what what do we you know what maybe
I'll make it Orange Parker another guy
here all right we got this couple man
woman right what does society like what
do we need for society to work we need a
house
um we might need the internet right I
mean we don't we don't need it but we we
all you know we need a car
hypothetically if you live in like I
know I can't draw I can't draw so just
you know bear with me
um we need electricity we need plumbing
and what percent of women do these jobs
so it's roughly 90 plus percent of men
are building the houses they're building
the cars they're doing the electricity
they're doing the plumbing
um I can't really think of one job where
women Dominate and that we need now this
is what they'll tell me right because I
got some I got some haters shocking
they'll say well women work at the DMV
women are teachers and health care now
here's here's the problem all of these
jobs men could easily learn on top of
that that Health Care is still roughly
50 50 and men still lead the way in
health care when it comes to the most
competitive and hardest jobs like brain
surgery you know research development
even inventions eighty percent men so my
question is if let's just say the green
guy is the guy if the men are making the
society run why are women starting to
out earn men because that's a new
feminist talking point that I hear oh
well the women are coming up now you
know we're starting to out earn men now
I'm going to give you two reasons that
women are out earning men we can
monetize and I'm going to give you an
example of this at the highest levels
who offers more value to society Kim
Kardashian or Elon Musk Kylie Jenner or
Elon Musk or Kylie Jenner Bill Gates
these are two female billionaires and
two male billionaires the male
billionaire is trying to put Life on
Mars electric cars
um you know software companies where the
female billionaires are monetizing
Beauty
um so that's one way that women out earn
men and we can even see this in
Corporate America like women I worked in
sales as a woman you have as have an
inherent advantage in sales because
you're a woman you're pretty to look at
they're going to talk to you easier than
a man and the men know this so you know
typically when women do get ahead it's
in places where you can monetize your
beauty now the second place reason
subsidizing there are a bunch of
government jobs and grants that reward
Corporate America for hiring women so we
take tax paying my the man friends and
we give it to the women because you know
they tax the men take the money from the
men and create Grant and programs to
reward Corporate America for hiring
women but does that mean the women are
offering equally as much value no so the
crazy thing is is that women are getting
these high paying jobs that men are
really paying for and guys you're gonna
ask me the data numbers but let's just
look in real life what happened at
Twitter Elon Musk said okay we got to
make money we're losing money look at
the before and after picture they got
rid of all the women all the women were
gone there was just a couple left now
this is not to say that women have no
place in society but as a whole we all
think we're more important than we are
you know there's always been exceptions
in history for you know high IQ women
making advancements in society but it's
the exception it's not the rule and
unfortunately I'm also really tired
tired of us acting like teachers are
like a godsend one all of these you know
the crazy thing is the industries that
women run are the industries We complain
about so Healthcare is mostly women
we're always complaining about how
health care is not there to help you
same with teachers okay colleges the
institutions run by women we all
complain about so one the teachers are
these single feminist women that don't
have kids of their own so they just try
to indoctrinate yours um Healthcare
everybody complains about how health
care gives you drugs and it doesn't fix
the problem so let's be honest if women
left left work and went back into the
home you would need less health care
because you'd actually have the mother
caring about what the kids eat we have a
whole generation of people that don't
know how to cook that don't know proper
nutrition because the mom instead of
being at home was busy teaching other
kids working in healthcare working at
the DMV all right then teaching now you
have the state teaching your kids where
again if the mom was home
she could homeschool the kids and you
wouldn't need any of these industries so
my point is if women stopped working
tomorrow I actually I think we would
have an increase in efficiency not a
decrease not a decrease and the problem
is we have all these women that think
they're doing more than they are because
they're hot and they make money off of
being hot and they're subsidized by the
government so yeah ladies we are not as
special as we think we are but you know
could be wrong let me know what you guys
think of the comments like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
and I'll talk to you next time